Tên xí hoặc mình sơn là tiền xí ký thuật từ động hóa
Tối nghiệm đại học tổng hợp kií thuật restaurant của đất
Ông công tác tạc tạc đại học ấy khóa hành hội từ năm 2020
Được phong phó giáo sư năm 2020
Tương đảm nhận nhiều vị trí lãnh đạo trước khi được bộ nhẹp thứ trường
Bộ giáo sức bộ đau tạo và tháng 1 năm 2020
Tháng 7 năm 2020, hủ trọng hàm lắm
Ông giữ trước trụ tịch hội đồng đại học
Giám đốc đại học của gia hành hội
Tạy đại hội mình muốn cứ đảng
Ông được bộ và văn chứ hành trung đảng phó mùi bốn
Và được giới thiệu ứng cụ đại biểu khu hội của mình sấu
Bởi nhường năm kinh nghiệm khoản lý giáo sức
Ông được ký vọc tiếp tục thuật đại đổi mới
Nên cao trước lượng giáo sức đạo tạo trong dự đảng mới